i want europe  to become the first climate neutral  continent  in the world by 2050.  european green deal could be a  cornerstone for changing our politics  [Music]  most importantly is the works which are  going to be done  [Music]  appropriate support for new obligations  we need everyone and no one will get  lifted  [Music]  as we continue to battle the pandemic  we must also focus on our long-term  challenges  this is why the green deal as a growth  strategy remains our compass  throughout the recovery we will reduce  emissions  by at least 55 by 2030  and today's agreement puts us on a clear  path  towards climate neutrality in 2050  it gives certainty to investors to  businesses  to public authorities and to citizens  it future proves our union